it's normally a time of great joy
parents welcoming a baby into the world
but what happens when coronavirus enters
the picture the news I tested positive
meant I'd have to give birth on my own
without my husband the two days ahead of
the birth were incredibly stressful I
was so afraid for my baby
poor little faith with coffered 19 still
infecting people what are the risks of
pregnancy and childbirth
[Music]
little can be more exciting than the
arrival of a newborn can it even though
it naturally comes with its anxieties
particularly for first-time parents
however those anxieties have been added
to for those welcoming a baby into a
world ravaged by coronavirus 3 newborn
babies who all tested positive for kovat
19 neither of the triplets parents have
the coronavirus health officials in San
Luis Potosi state in Mexico are calling
the case unprecedented what we need to
consider here is whether the corona
virus could have been transmitted
through the placenta that's not
something that we can be sure of at this
time it's a theory that we have to look
at it's a new virus there's no
international literature yet but this
will be worth reviewing it's just one
example that highlights how much is yet
to be discovered about the impact the
virus can have before and during birth
what we do know is based on limited data
early studies suggest that pregnant
women aren't more likely to fall
severely ill from kovat 19 most newborns
who test positive will recover but there
have been some cases of infant's falling
severely ill transmission from mother to
baby via breast milk appears unlikely so
several cases have been identified where
there have been RNA fragments or
fragments of the virus in breast milk
but we haven't actually identified life
virus in breast milk and so the risk of
transmission from mother to child
therefore so far has not been
established over in Colombia pregnant
women are among the hundreds of migrants
who've been trying to cross back into
Venezuela as the virus dampens their
prospects of setting up a new life
border closures part of lockdown
restrictions have left them waiting days
to access humanitarian corridors
ditions are dire not least for expectant
mothers were hungry we've no place to
cook and as long as we've no money we'll
stay hungry
whether it's overstretched Health
Services restrictions on movement or
simply a lack of data giving birth
during a pandemic is especially
anxiety-inducing but with every new life
comes the prospect of a brighter future
free of covet 19 we can now speak to
Mandy Mangler she's the lead doctor at
the vivant his clinic for gynecology and
obstetrics here in Berlin dr. manga
thanks for joining us how different is
giving birth now to even just a few
months ago before the pandemic yes hello
so a few things have changed obviously
depending on your local healthcare
system and where you give birth and how
the infection load in your country is
but many women are confronted with
visiting rules in the hospital so they
might have to give birth alone and might
not be able to be visited after birth so
this is what has changed significantly
yeah and if you've got these extra
restrictions in hospital visiting issues
etc imagine that might be quite
off-putting for some mothers to be so
are some mothers choosing not to give
birth in hospitals where they might have
otherwise yes some mothers choose to
have home
Bertha's or they might go to a hospital
to give birth and leave the hospital
very shortly after the birth so this
would be a good solution not to stay in
the hospital but many hospitals have
have taken extra care of mothers and of
their newborn babies so depending on the
local system you are confronted with you
might have a secure solution in your
health care system or a solution where
you are affected with the possibility of
infections with your home versus
say would you water others against home
births they were where possible would
you be urging them despite you know the
fact that you know hope they might
worried about hospitals you know they've
got patients in them that have got
coronavirus but would you still be
advising mothers to go to hospital well
yes I would
many upset rewards have have a cocoon
strategy there cocooning their
obstetrical words they protected from
infections and from other patients from
the hospital so it depends on what
health care system you have but home
birth is carry an extra risk of well not
being medically assist that during your
birth and there are so many risks coming
with this that advising everybody to be
at home giving birth is not nothing i
would say and all these restrictions are
aiming to prevent both the mother and
the baby contracting copy 19 themselves
but you have dealt with babies who have
got the condition how do you approach
that well there's a national germany
guideline how to deal with infected
babies there was there's a for a long
time it was known that babies are not
prone to be infected via the blood of an
infected mother but anyway we have seen
some babies being infected even babies
from caesarean sections so any any birth
away could lead to an infected baby if
the mother is infected and the national
guideline coping with these infected
babies says that you should not restrict
the mother from the baby take the baby
away from the family you should as a
mother if you're infected or not take
extra care of the baby and have high
hygiene standards but breastfeed anyway
and not give the baby away so because
babies are not a risk group even if they
contract coronavirus they might not be
severely ill or most of the babies will
not be severely ill doctor Mandy
from the vivant EES clinic for
gynecology and obstetrics here in Berlin
thank you so much for your time and now
it's your chance to ask the questions to
our science correspondent Derek Williams
when will this pandemic be over yeah
that's the the trillion dollar question
isn't it I wish I could answer it but
right now no one can
the w-h-o has broken influenza pandemics
down into six stages and they're only
considered over when levels of flu have
returned to stable pre-pandemic levels
but but if the definition of an end to
the kovat 19 pandemic means reaching a
stable number of infections worldwide
then we still have a very long way to go
in the absence of measures like social
distancing the number of new infections
will only stabilize with the advent of
herd immunity when an estimated 60 to
70% of the Earth's population has been
infected and recovered but a huge
vaccination program with a highly
effective vaccine would of course
accelerate that process so while we can
say that this pandemic - will certainly
one day end there's still way too many
factors in play for anyone to say
exactly when that day will be is there a
chance of vaccine could cause the virus
to grow more deadly to even attempt to
answer it you have to look at what other
vaccines have done - viruses in the past
vaccines of course contribute to - viral
evolution by driving selection as more
and more people in a population acquire
immunity strains for example that
evolved to be more highly contagious
would would have at least a temporary
advantage but what advantages would
growing more deadly bring Sarris cough -
I mean if people began dying
even more than they are now vigilance
would would ramp up even higher and that
would lead to less spread so it's not
actually in the virus's best interest to
grow more deadly it's to infect as many
people as possible so I'd say that while
there's there's no question vaccines
push viruses to evolve I don't believe
in this case it'll push them to evolve
in the direction of greater virulence in
fact I'd expect a vaccine to push it to
be less virulent but more contagious but
that's just my best guess can you get
kovat 19 from an open wound or cut to
invade the body
Sarris cove 2 has to latch on to what's
called the ACE 2 receptor which is is
quite abundant in the membranes of cells
in the upper respiratory tract as well
as in a range of different organs
including your lungs and your kidneys
and your heart ace 2 is a kind of door
knob that allows the virus to enter
those cells in tissue made up of cells
that have a few or no ace 2 receptors
like like your skin and subcutaneous
tissue the door is effectively locked so
all the evidence indicates that that
even if Sora's Cove 2 got into an open
scratch it wouldn't be able to turn into
a full-blown infection because it
wouldn't be able to invade the cells
effectively or spread effectively in
that tissue to do that it has to invade
tissue like the membranes in your upper
respiratory tract which which carry lots
of ace 2
you